pop
[Musique]
sa mère est corse et son père auvergnat
l'homme au cigare c'est michel charasse
un cas parmi la classe politique
française
car ce travailleur acharné dont le
franc-parler ne laisse personne
indifférent cultive involontairement
l'art du paradoxe
la preuve ce socialiste est né en 1941 à
chamalières le fief de valéry giscard
d'estaing en avions deux fois par
semaine
l'aller retour et je travaille presque
tout le temps dans l'avion parce que
c'est un endroit très tranquille même
s'il m'arrive de prendre le train je
travaille aussi d'ailleurs
on n'est pas dérangé ya pas de téléphone
personnes frappent à la porte pour pour
entrer dans un bureau
demander quelque chose donc c'est ses
cinquante minutes de tranquillité
absolue
vous êtes en liaison constante avec
l'elysée lorsque vous êtes dans votre
bureau téléphone ici y'a pas de
téléphone non mais l'élysée peut
m'appeler par le commandant de bord nous
avons commencé notre adepte à paris-orly
nous vous demandons à vouloir attachez
votre ceinture batterie l'allemagne
les allées du pouvoir il les fréquente
au plus haut niveau depuis que la gauche
a gagné les élections présidentielles de
1981 michel charasse étant depuis ce
qu'on appelle un homme du président et
seule chose dont je ne m'occupe pas ici
c'est la question à l'envers
j'ai pas été appelé auprès du président
pour suivre plus particulièrement les
affaires d'une région d'ailleurs il
faudrait dans ce cas là que toutes les
régions de france et représentant dans
cette maison où il y en a beaucoup de
gens comme vous aussi le président a une
bonne trentaine de collaborateurs civils
et militaires
c'est ce qu'on appelle la maison du
président sa maison le président de la
république par exemple est ce que vous a
déjà fait un reproche non et vous a
jamais dit telle chose il faudrait
peaufiner un petit peu ce secteur si ça
arrive mais sur ce point un vrai
reproche donc on peut pas faire que des
choses qui font plaisir tout le temps
qu'ils soient parfaites lycée lit mais
bon
mais ça c'est pas dire proche et c'est
le dialogue quotidien
la question qu'on se pose c'est que
pense le président de la république de
michel charasse et l'on pense du bien
je n'en sais rien il faut lui demandait
le chef de l'état qui s'est déjà rendu
en visite dans la commune dont michel
charasse et le premier magistrat
guillaume dans le puy-de-dôme c'était le
21 août 1982 pour le mariage de la fille
de dee ligier le constructeur automobile
un ami du maire et du président en
auvergne je ne suis que mr conseil
régional et sénateur
oui enfin je suis pas un homme surchargé
de mandat j'ai des collègues qui ajoute
en plus le conseil général d'autres
organismes parallèle au conseil général
moi je n'ai que trois mandats dont on
suit conseil régional qui est dérivé de
suite sénateurs puisque au sexe et de
droit quand on est parlementaire
concierge au conseil régional
donc je suis pas une accumulation
excessive de mandat j'ai pas d'autres
attributions sauf le secrétaire général
de l'association des maires
ce camp je suis pas sûr car j'ai aimé
mandat me suffisent
j'ai assez de travail
les papillons valider ses juges tiennent
pas les vieux bon pitch ancien joueur de
saragosse et oui parce que s'ils
agissent dossier la batterie tient pas
alors maintenant capable
après guillaume situé entre les deux
vallée de la dore et de l'allier c'est
en 1977 qu'il est élu maire pour la
première fois puis guillaume dont la
principale industrie emploie plus de 700
personnes des verreries d'où sortent eux
près d'un demi milliard de bouteilles
chaque année être à la tête d'une
commune c'est bien dit michel charasse
car là on voit ce qu'on fait l'aspect
qui m'embête le plus c'est que les gens
ont parfois le sentiment d'une injustice
lorsqu'on leur donne pas satisfaction
alors que on leur a expliqué qu'on
pouvait pas et souvent on a de bonnes
raisons de pas pouvoir bonnes raisons
mais des raisons légitimes qui touche à
l'intérêt général
et lorsqu'il quitte mon cabinet en se
disant que c'est injuste je suis très
peiné à l'est
[Musique]
j'ai un ordre du jour de conseil ce soir
gratiné gratiné je vous engage donc mes
chers collègues a autorisé notre
sénateur maire engagé toutes les
formalités nécessaires et à signer les
actes et à intervenir
très bien je remercie monsieur laurent
pineau pour son rapport très clair pas
d'opposition je vous remercie
il en est ainsi décidé tablons
développement communaux jaras un
animateur qui abat un énorme travail
disent de lui ce qu'il aime bien
alors que les autres l'ont surnommé le
baron de puy-guillaume cela dit ces
spécialités sont multiples le budget
l'intérieur la loi électorale et les
textes en général qu'il connaît comme sa
poche et lieu dans sa ville à 53 puis
58% liste socialiste dissidente s'est
cependant présenter contre lui en 83 une
liste qui dit-il est une auberge
espagnole
regroupant les déçus du chat racisme le
poste de maire dans une petite commune
comme celle ci qui est une commune
modeste 2706 habitants c'est un poste
qui est très chargé
parce que nous avons des services de
qualité mais en nombre insuffisant peut
pas se permettre d'avoir un personnel
pléthorique et par conséquent le maire
doit et les adjoints doivent beaucoup
prendre sur leur temps et sur eux mêmes
pour faire beaucoup de choses depuis que
je suis sénateur
j'ai fait plus de quarante mille
interventions j'ai baisé pas publiés
dans le journal je suis très sollicité
j'ai beaucoup de courrier je réponds à
mon courrier
j'ai beaucoup d'affaires dans ma commune
on perd pas de temps je suis une des
communes qui utilisent le plus
rapidement l'argent qu'elle reçoit des
subventions départementales et
régionales
tout ça ça demande du travail alors je
le fais je dirige les choses avec la
fermeté nécessaire à propos d' autorité
vous n'êtes pas l'homme de droite du
parti socialiste nous on que ce succès
canard non mais pourquoi pourquoi
l'autorité serait incompatible avec le
socialisme c'est pas socialiste ce n'est
pas la pagaille
les choses peuvent se faire bien que
dans l'ordre ce qui n'exclut pas la
liberté
les mouvements de chacun les idées de
chacun mais enfin bon je vois pas
pourquoi ce qu'on serait socialiste on
serait automatiquement partisans de la
pagaille du laisser-aller de tout ce
qu'on peut imaginer
vous avez des amis à droite oui pourquoi
c'est pas interdit
quelqu'un a bien des gens de droite qui
ont des amis à gauche mais je veux pas
faire une sélection parce que si je dis
intel je le trouve très bien ça veut
dire que je trouve les autres pas bien
or il ya plusieurs enfants dans la
maison du père
vous attendiez à de telles difficultés
pour la gauche en france par rapport à
mai 81 oui parce que toutes les fois
qu'on a appelé la gauche dans ce pays
c'est que la france était en difficulté
quand les choses vont bien on n'appelle
pas la gauche
nous avons une vocation d'être les
pompiers de service quand la maison
brûle
[Musique]
moi je suis collaborateurs choisis
personnellement part au président
révocables par lui il m'a fait un grand
honneur et une grande amitié en me
demandant travaillé auprès de lui ou
plutôt de continuer à travailler auprès
de lui puisque j'avais déjà eu
l'occasion avant 1980 dans le cadre de
mes fonctions parlementaires socialistes
à l'assemblée
c'était le 12 mai j'ai été très très
surpris très flatté très content et très
embêté parce que j'avais promis à gaston
defferre qui est un de mes vieux amis de
le suivre au ministère de l'intérieur
comme il me l'avait d'ailleurs demandé
et comme une promesse est une promesse
j'ai donc dû demander à gaston defferre
de me délier de mon serment et j'ai pas
eu besoin de faire cette démarche
puisque le président de la république
l'a fait lui-même auprès de gaston
defferre et toi t'es calmer pour des
instituteurs des calmes et pour des
instituteurs il m'avait raconter des
craques
tu comprends et par conséquent le gâta
d'éminence grise
nous sommes ici
confiné dans la nécessité d'être discret
voilà monsieur sa race quel est votre
rôle exact
ici à l'elysée écoutez c'est la seule
question à laquelle je peux pas vous
répondre et non pas que ce que je
faisais soit il la voit bien au
contraire mais parce que les fonctions
qui nous sont confiées sont intuiti
personae
il n'est pas souhaitable qu on s'étend
au dessus
je n'ai pas envie d'être ministre ou non
ça me tente pas et votre poste vous êtes
au dessus des ministres en dessous juste
en dessous où vous situez-vous on est à
côté du président à côté et en dessous
du chef de l'état précise michel
charasse qui appuient guillaume est
heureux auprès de son arbre fougueux
comme son chien safran se battant de la
vie politique après si contrairement à
ce qu'on pourrait croire les activités
plutôt calme comme la lecture la marche
ou la pêche
monsieur le sénateur maire conseiller du
président qui est marié avec une
institutrice lui dans la maison a une
histoire puisque françois mitterrand et
a séjourné pendant la deuxième guerre
mondiale
en 1943
joli jardin c'est le socialisme qui
volent sociale inss est une occasion en
79 j'ai acheté ça pour un prix tout à
fait raisonnables n'avais pas envie
d'être riche très riche
non j'en ai assez pour vivre enfin je
suis pas un homme d'argent moi j'ai
suffit que j'ai de quoi couvrir mes
besoins qui sont pas tapageur
je fais rien d'extraordinaire dans ma
vie je ne dépense pas l'argent à
considérer manger pad a envie
particulière
j'aime le cinéma la musique donc lui
aussi et puis bull et comme il est
pratiquement trois ans par semaine pas
uniquement puisque uniquement le
dimanche c'est tout mais vous savez
qu'ils s'ennuient en vacances on parlait
plus de 10 jours parce qu'au bout de dix
jours et il sait de quoi faire vous
trouverez un petit peu trop autoritaire
non non qu'il a avec moi vous savez que
c'est un petit reproche qu'on lui fait
oui je sais pas ce que c'est un
caractère emporté en plus d'aller la
visiter tout de suite dit trouver ce
qu'ils pensent voilà qu'un bon dieu sur
hbo c'est quelque chose
la fameuse d'utiles conseils et des amis
de la base voilà exactement c'est un
peuple
je vois qu'on essaie de se faire des tas
oui question idiote
moi personne pourra jamais que j'ai
menti dit la vérité
alors quand ils ont trouvé la vérité
sachant qu'ils avaient commencé quand on
crée type est un con way je n'ai pas
peur à le faire des ronds de jambes je
lui ai dit vous êtes encore il a droit
de penser la même chose de moi
ils s'en font pas faute d'ailleurs il
est possible que je sois un conte pour
moi j'en fus pas ou bien serrer un peu
la seule chose qu'on peut nous reprocher
c'est pas avoir été rigoureux assez tôt
c'est vraiment moi je prends au suffrage
universel
celui qui mange non ça plaira plus
rapide on irait jusqu'à franck et là il
n'a pas eu de chance dans sa vie qui n'a
pas eu la chance de souffrir
la dernière fois que vous avez tout le
reste et campe le m oui halford
présidentielle c'était l'aboutissement
d'un combat qui pour moi occupé 20 en
elle et c'est ainsi que michel charasse
assistant privilégié à tous les grands
événements de la république
une chance pour ce diplômé de l'institut
d'études politiques de paris qui jadis
s'est fait les dents au ministère de
l'économie et des finances après s'est
inscrit au parti socialiste en 1962 en
raison de son refus de la guerre
d'algérie et des conditions du
référendum de l'époque constamment côtés
de françois mitterrand depuis 1971 son
titre officiel aujourd'hui ses
conseillers auprès du secrétaire général
de l'elysée c'est pourquoi outre sa
participation à certaines réunions
interministérielles
tous les mercredis matins il examine les
projets de communiqué pour le conseil
des ministres et ce en compagnie d'un
noyau de conseillers qui sont les très
proche collaborateur de françois
mitterrand
chacun d'entre eux a ses propres
qualités mais michel charasse est réputé
pour être le plus efficace
et c'est justement à ce propos il faut
se demander où s'arrêtera l'ascension de
l'excellent juristes qui l'est c'est
important cela dit c'est une nation
plique
joue un rôle d'opposant ce qui n'est pas
forcément pour plaire mais c'est dans la
nature même du régime démocratique qui
l'origine vous êtes ici jusqu'à quelle
date normalement 1992
[Musique]